everything's dated i guess you go around
the country most things are dated there
there are still malls you know people
still go out to the mall and eat a
pretzel and walk around and try on
clothes in a fitting room
and you go no you don't do that you buy
the clothes on the internet you don't go
to the mall anymore you don't have to go
to the mall
i understand that it's nice i guess
to walk around a mall but you don't have
to do it you're walking around a mall
you almost feel like you're walking
around
alcatraz you're walking around a place
that shouldn't exist anymore and does
and it's weird and then the food court's
there
and uh they've always got like a chinese
restaurant a chinese restaurant with
like a weird name it's always kind of
vaguely racist you know it's like mr
wangs or something
and it's just people that you'll just
see people they're just eating lo mein
with like a dickies bag and they just
want to go get put a pants on at dickies
and now they're gonna eat [ __ ] lo
mein 3 000 calories
ms and msg and go home and the pants
don't fit you know
it's it we haven't figured out a lot of
[ __ ] on this planet we're not evolving
that quickly you'd think we'd be
evolving at a little quicker pace
we're really not because the only other
option is the internet which also sucks
because you get it doesn't fit
you're on the internet that's alienating
and sad you're like jacking it and then
you're like all right i gotta buy
clothes and then
i'm fighting with my aunt on facebook
and then what i want an nft
and it's not good you've set up this
digital world for yourself that sucks
but the real world also sucks like now
that things are opening you start to
realize
man the real world kind of sucks a
little bit too
not all of it there's some great things
out there but a lot of the things
like there's no evolution like we
haven't built a cooler newer version of
them all
there's no cool or newer version of
these things you know what i mean
like it just feels the only the only
thing we've done is made them for rich
people
so we've just built malls for wealthy
people like we've made malls and go whoa
everything's gucci and here's
sugar fish sushi and and that's all
we've done but there's there's
not a lot of new things happening
out there but we you know and you'll
notice this as you open up
opening up is going to be very
interesting someone's going to be out
there like this is
[ __ ] great and they're going to look
around and go the country's kind of
shocked
they're gonna be like finally i'm back
uh you start looking around you start
noticing
how decrepid most things are you might
walk right back in your house
after that by the way you might tiptoe
right the [ __ ] back in your front door
sit down and say [ __ ] it because when
you go back out you realize
that covert was the nail in the coffin
for just said like a lot of these
businesses
and a lot of these you know the public
parks are bad
like the public park is just homeless in
the park
and there's there's like hiking trails i
guess
in parts of the country but the country
looks bad it looks shot
the country is a cancer patient the
country's on dialysis
the country's got a late stage venal
disease
and and and we are like we're all going
to go back
out in it and then start to realize that
like oh things
things need help we need to like things
need a little lipstick and rouge out
there it's not
you know we were in a we're in a
restaurant the other day a friday's type
of restaurant that we had to be in
and you're looking around and i know
these places have been through hell so
don't yell at me and go you
know like when i uploaded that photo of
cleveland of the the steel mill and i'm
like
cleveland's a lovely city and they go
that's american steel
what do you want the tacoms to do to
steal i'm like no
it just looks gross i'm sorry it looks
bad i know it serves a
function it's just it's all smog and
smoke and it looks like [ __ ]
i understand could we have a city with
steel plants and not have people walking
around dressed in reynolds rap
is that possible that we don't have to
have boarded up houses and people
walking around in cellophane
that's all i'm sorry i i wasn't making
an anti-steel post
on my instagram but how how perceptive
of you that's
american steel dummy good
i'm just saying when you get back out
there it's not gonna be
i don't know what you're expecting it's
like not seeing
someone for a while you don't see
someone for a while
and then they walk in and you go god
god how's it been
you know how bad you look if somebody
comes up to you and they're like how's
it been
have you been you okay you okay
like that's what america is going to
look like when we all go back and go you
okay
say okay are you okay just waitresses
shaking
trying to put entrees down on the table
nobody's had any money everybody's
spent all their money on soldier boys
nft
cities are just descending into chaos
you have just people shooting each other
all the time
crime is on the rise everywhere
except online except it is on the rise
online you know
it's like school shootings came back as
soon as
indoor classes started mark norman had a
tweet it was like we're back
school shootings are back i mean i want
everything to open up and i want to go
back after but also realize what's
coming with that it's not all going to
be sunshine and song
there's going to be some i mean kids
have not shot each other in
a year like they're ready to go kids are
ready to shoot each other they're
teachers
administrators they're ready to go on
like day one that kid came in and just
started firing wildly on day one
i mean i think the teachers should start
shooting the kids when they go back
i hope teachers start shooting kids when
schools open up again
i hope teachers just turn around and
start shooting them in their little
[ __ ] heads
that's what i hope happens that's what's
going to happen when things open up
when things open up you can go out to
eat people are going to forget your
balsamic vinaigrette again and you're
gonna sit there with your hands clenched
and you're gonna want to go up and hit
them they're gonna bring the appetizers
and the entrees
at the same [ __ ] time like they don't
know that's a problem
again that's coming back yes you'll be
able to leave your house
yes but things are coming back with it
the long line at the car wash
will be back because people aren't
afraid
crowded public transportation is coming
back
all back you could sit in a movie
theater next to some vector of disease
a diner where you can watch a divorced
dad try to bond with his son who hates
him
that's all coming back you're gonna have
to see your family again
thanksgiving might [ __ ] happen this
year you're gonna have to sit down next
to aunt
q anon and uncle drunk touches you and
you're gonna have to
sit there and choke down mashed potatoes
next to those two
all because of this dumb vaccine which
we could have just avoided
thanksgiving's gonna be back your office
is back you haven't seen doreen in a
while
she's back hi we're back
who wants coffee the office office
life's coming back
sit there and talk to chuck he just
started watching the americans
he thinks he's living next to a
communist spy chuck's gonna fill you in
on that in the break room
that's coming back get excited your kids
are gonna go to start
going to school again it's gonna be much
easier for them to get heroin and
[ __ ] in the mouth that's happening
your daughter's gonna have a venereal
disease in about six months because we
vaccinated everybody and we're ready to
go so that's back if
she doesn't get shot in the face by one
of these anti-social kids who spent the
last 12 months reading about bitcoin so
that's back
you happy you happy you got your second
shot
and you're back now traffic will be back
it's already kind of back
you could sit in traffic you got that
long commute to work
pass by billboards of televangelists and
healthcare companies that
denied you you could pull in your little
[ __ ] thing at your data entry job
go in there sit down next to somebody
named michelle
and you guys sit there and you walk in
and there's a crusty donut left from
yesterday but you just put that down
your throat
and you get to have a nice [ __ ]
caramel latte that's 2 800 calories
and it buzzes you up for only 45 minutes
and then you got to start taking the
pills
cause nothing else works that's coming
back
open it up open it all
up it's coming
and don't you worry about it i'm just
saying
hey i know we need to open up but let's
do it with open eyes
let's open up with open eyes here
maybe we don't have to go back to
everything we did
maybe we can be smarter and safer okay
about some of the things that we used to
do
you know that's all that's all i'm
saying i'm not saying don't be excited
about i'm excited about it
i'm excited about everything opening up
again and i want to see everyone i've
missed for the last year it i've been
very
all these young kids are killing
themselves because they
i have no friends i'm going to kill
myself when i'm forced to see my friends
again
do you understand the difference i've
been on the planet long enough to know
you don't kill yourself when you have no
friends
it's a mark of virtue to not have any
friends most people don't realize that
it's actually biblical christ didn't
have any friends
exactly but i'm excited for things to
come back hope
i know that people don't people probably
say i feel like he's not but i am it's
going to be fun
things are coming back we're going to do
a bunch of crazy cool [ __ ]
uh when we're allowed to do it at
capacity really cool weird comedy
experiences
uh that we're trying to work with
different people and companies and
investors to do and
and [ __ ] like that and i'm pumped about
it
i just i just know that it's going to be
funny because and it's just human nature
everyone is begging for everything to
open because we need it to open by the
way there's no other option we can't
just stay in our homes
but it's just going gonna be funny the
first time you start complaining again
about
the open world because that'll have like
the first time you're like oh
[ __ ] first time you walk into a store
she's packed
like [ __ ] this it's true it's coming the
first
complaint you have about remember how
nice l.a was with no traffic when
everyone was scared to death they were
scared in their homes
they were just scared terrified of
leaving their homes
the way it should be and then
now the traffic's back out people are
having quincy and errors on the beat get
off the beach
they're doing quinceaneras on the beach
in malibu
they're they're smashing pinatas on in
malibu on the beach
clean it up and echo and i'm not
it's quincy and era because it that's
what i saw
i don't care if it was a i don't want a
white [ __ ] there with a pinata either
so don't come at me i'm just saying
there's a lot of
fun stuff that's going to be happening
very soon
that will also anger you i've gotten a
little used to
um not seeing as many people
and i'm gonna obviously get used to
seeing more of them which will be lovely
and my fam i guess i'll have to see my i
guess at
some point i will have to see my family
my mother's in her nursing home they've
just locked her up no one can see her
i just wavered her through the window
and tell her what nft to buy
now i'm gonna have to go in there and
actually talk to her
which is fine but d you got to realize
what's about to happen here folks are
you prepared you got to just get ready
for it
bob and weave bob and you got to get
ready for it
many of you think you want it until it's
here
it's like anything you think you want it
and then it's here and then you're like
wait what but this digital hell can't
last
that's true we need to go out and see
people we need humanity we need real
friends
we need to look at them we need to
realize why we didn't talk to them that
much over the last year because they're
non-essential to us
that's the other thing if you didn't
talk to someone over the last year
it's really like i mean i know you'll go
out you'll patch those friendships to an
extent but like
there's going to be a lot of people that
reconnect with you after this whole
thing where you could be sitting there
going
looking at them going i don't need you
this year showed you what you needed
what you need you don't need a lot of
things and people you don't
this year simplified our lives in a
weird way
it complicated them but it also
simplified them you know what i mean
like i realized that all i need is ben
and then on the other side of this
camera 500 000 domestic terrorists
i don't need a lot i just need half a
million people many of whom are on a
watch list
and him i'm not i don't need a ton of
other
things going on in my life you know
you know i need a couple of good-looking
gentlemen with six packs or a little
younger that want
gucci shoes that's what i need i don't
need an
endless supply of social interactions i
find them to be
a little meaningless but i'm getting
older to 36.
you're getting older you know i get it
if this happened i was 22 i'd be like
man of [ __ ] i can't believe it
dude what now i'm like i'm
dr i'm like dreading i pray every day i
turn on the tv i pray for the new strain
i pray that people's faces start melting
off with this
i go come on i roll the dice i'm like
give me
brazil give me brazil because i'm just
trying to avoid thanksgiving so i'm like
roll the dice come on give me something
from pakistan give it to me good
i don't know it won't be over that soon
but it'll be over soon enough i
i do hope it ends we need new things we
need new things to be angry at and mad
at and we need new uh challenges in life
we need to go out there and
people need to [ __ ] again and meet each
other and have physical
relationships you know i mean i get it
you know but
it's a very interesting thing to be just
let out of the cage
just let out of the cage like
here's the reality when you let the kids
out of the ice cage many of them were
like hey man
it sucked in there but this is also bad
wherever they put them i don't know you
know what i mean
should i broadcast from one of the biden
administration ice cages
for a week because biden hasn't shut
them down either
just go live just go live should i just
do like a 48-hour live event
from a detention from an immigration
detention facility
i mean can we sell
immigrant children as nfts
to release them that that's a question
can we sell children detained
at the immigration center as nfts can
mark cuban do that
can mark cuban take a picture of a child
in a cage
dancing sell it raise the money to get
that little guy out
and we'd have to explain to him jose
you're an nft
now you're a non-fungible token
okay you're a non-fungible token you're
out of here
and we turn to the next one and go
you're not a non-fungible token yet
back in i'm laughing i of course are for
abolishing the cages so don't get angry
at me i don't want
any children in cages and i never did so
don't
oh i'm making fun of a horrible
situation you know
i also didn't want the my life massacre
you know i'm not involved in the
decision making